hello
here are mary jane and tommy davis
let's follow them into the classroom
miss allen is going to speak
she gives out special project
assignments on sleep good posture and
mary jane and tommy are assigned mouth
help
they wonder what in the world they can
do with the subject on mouth health
the study of oral hygiene just doesn't
seem to suggest anything for a project
they don't realize
how interesting it really can be
of course their friend dr wilson the
family dentist will help them
hmm wonder if he's busy
miss young the dental assistant welcomes
mary jane and tommy
they tell her about their project
assignment
the dentist artist dr wilson has just
finished cleaning carol's teeth as he
has done every four months since she was
two years
since the dentist is busy miss young
takes the children into the waiting room
to show them a book which may suggest
some ideas for their project
each year carol has had an x-ray of her
teeth which would have shown a dark spot
if she had a small cavity
the x-ray is a detective which indicates
the positions of the permanent teeth
which are forming here below the first
or deciduous teeth
this early detection helps to prevent
larger and more expensive fillings later
in the meantime ms young has been
showing the children pictures of the
first or deciduous teeth of a
six-year-old child
the permanent teeth are forming at the
ends of the roots of the deciduous teeth
as we noticed in the x-ray
ms young suggests that since tomorrow is
a holiday she will take them to see the
orthodontist dr martin who has many
dental models and charts
and besides dr martin may even let them
write his son's pony
well here they are at dr martin's home
office
looks as if his son scotty is getting a
pony ride
miss young will go with scotty so that
dr martin can take more time from his
laboratory work to show the children the
exhibits
let's listen in
in this exhibit mary jane and tommy
notice how the shape of the face changes
as the jaws and teeth develop
at birth teeth are already forming in
the jaws yet the first tooth doesn't
appear in the mouth until about six
months of age
between five and a half to seven and a
half years of age the first permanent or
sixth year molars make their appearance
back of all the first teeth
they are the most important since they
influence the position of all the other
teeth
at 14 years of age the shape of the face
has taken on adult proportions
all the permanent teeth are in the mouth
with the exception of the third molars
or wisdom teeth
which come in sometime after the 17th
year
now let's go into the garden and discuss
these models of children's teeth
they are good examples of orthodontics
or the straightening of teeth
now here's a picture of a boy who sucked
his thumb when he was a baby
notice how the upper teeth protrude and
the chin recedes
and see how his appearance has been
improved by orthodontic treatment
this is a plaster of paris model the
boy's teeth
before
and after correction
now tommy
you know that sleeping or resting the
face on the hand may cause irregular
jaws and teeth also
now that miss young is back the dentist
invites his guests to the lunch that has
been set out in the backyard
this properly balanced meal consists of
celery which exercises the jaws and
teeth
a lettuce and tomato salad and milk the
most important of all foods
deviled eggs
whole grain bread and butter
and fruits complete the lunch
since it is good practice to clean the
teeth following each meal miss young
offers to demonstrate an accepted method
of tooth brushing
let's hear what she says
follow a regular tooth brushing method
and always begin at a definite place
put the brush high up on the gums with
the bristles pointing with the roots of
the teeth use considerable pressure
brushing toward the chewing surfaces
this enables the bristles to penetrate
and clean between the teeth
continue around the mouth and repeat on
the inside
make eight to ten sweeps in the same
location
and again on the lowers
brush toward the chewing surfaces inside
and outside
use a back and forth and be sure to
scrub them well
with all that they have learned it is
now easy as well as entertaining for
mary jane and tommy to make their school
project
even the neighbors twins are inspected
what
no teeth
with their prep book finished they
proudly take it to school to present it
to miss allen
the title of the book was you have a
smile
we know how much a dollar is and how
much